Totally deaf,
religious founds,
a Scifi innovative military heroin.
There's a lot of question marks when
it comes to l dot Ron Hubbard's life,
the life story he is told over the years
and the life story that many of his
fellow is point to is not the same
story that documents and other official
sources tell the details
of his life or uncertain.
There is no question that his life was
a fascinating trip from a midwestern
childhood to an internationally
recognized right on and influence that
the man who rose to influence some of
Hollywood's biggest names was born far
from the lands of Celebrity Hubbard
was born in 1911 in Nebraska.
His mother was a teacher and his father
was a military man when Hubbard was only
to his family,
moved from Nebraska to Montana,
and Hubbard grew up in a townhouse that
we as made claims that the family lived
on a ranch,
but that's just one of many claims that
has been debunked by family members,
government officials,
and others who actually knew Hubbard
as he was growing up and starting his
career.
[inaudible] father was in the navy,
been traveled around the world,
but Hubbard didn't accompany
him outside of the country.
Some stories about hubbards teen life
do suggest that he lived in places like
China and Guam and Japan,
but it's not clear if this is in fact
part of his official life or part of the
mystique built up around him and the
study of eastern medicine as part of his
scientology persona.
Truly separating fact from fiction is
difficult when it comes to Hubbard's life.
The Hubbard family briefly
lived in Washington state
and Hubbard attended school
for some years on the west coast,
then return to Montana as a finished high
school and live with his grandparents
and his parents lived overseas.
After graduating from high school,
I left the Midwest and headed east to
the nation's capital at George Washington
University.
He studied engineering but dropped out
after only two years due to failing
grades without a college degree
and no prospects ahead of him.
He turned to his imagination and his
began penning Saifai and horror stories to
earn a living.
He was only making a penny a word,
though meant you had to write prolifically
in order to earn enough to live on.
You don't get rich writing science
fiction if you want to get rich,
you start a religion.
Hubbard one said this as well.
He certainly knew what he was talking
about because he had to crank out so many
stories.
Hubbard now holds the Guinness World
Record for the most translated and
published author in the world.
During the 19 thirties,
he wrote under several pseudonyms and
wrote dozens of stories across nearly
every literary genre.
He published novels and some reports
even say that he wrote as many as 100,000
words a month.
Science fiction became
what he was best known for.
Anti even moved in the social circles
of men like Isaac Asimov and Robert
Heinlein,
hubbards racing.
It also caught the attention of Hollywood.
He wrote the script for the secret of
treasure islands and claims that he helped
write several other movies,
including John Ford stagecoach,
but his name doesn't actually appear
in the credits for this movie.
In the year 2000.
His work was prominently featured on the
big screen when his novel battlefield
Earth was made into a movie starring
none other than devout scientologist.
John Travolta,
right writing Korea like so many other
American men's careers was interrupted by
the outbreak of World War Two.
He joined the navy reserve in 1941.
Ends upon the recommendation
of his congressman.
He was made a lieutenants.
The stories of hubbards military career
have been polished and exaggerated for
the benefit of scientology.
Tales of overseas heroism abounds hands.
The scientology version of his war record
has been receiving 21 metals for his
actions during the war,
including injuries that
supposedly left him blind.
It cripples in reality,
though the story of hubbards military
service is a little bit different.
Official military records show that
he never actually left the continental
United States during the war,
and he also wasn't a hero far from his.
In fact,
he lost the command of his
ship after a number of mishaps,
including having his crew fire bought
what he thought was a submarine off the
coast of Oregon.
Well,
there's submarine.
It actually turned out to
be a large floating log,
even though Hubbard was
relieved of his command,
he was allowed to stay in
the navy on inactive duty.
It was in 1958.
He officially resigned his commission
and left the military behind for good.
Nobody's active students in the navy
where Nice stayed on the west coast moving
to Los Angeles in 1945.
He hadn't been married in 1933,
but his wife wouldn't bring along the
whole family to California from Washington
to live there.
Later Habits said his wife left
him because he was a cripple.
I was abandoned by family and friends as
a supposedly hopeless crippled mandate.
Probable burden upon them for the rest
of my days is how his version of the
stories of those ugly goes in
California without his wife or children.
Hubbard found himself with a new
family of sorts and unless the Crowley,
that famous practitioner of magic was
leading a group and some would say a cult
called auto,
temporally or orientalist.
Hubbard's joined the group and found
an outlet for his interest in science
fiction.
The occult and the fantastical.
How moved in with Jack Parsons
and his girlfriend Sarah Parsons,
or some members of the
group and the three,
they became close friends perhaps to
close because eventually hubbards began
sleeping with Parsons girlfriends and
Parsons didn't seem to mind seeing them.
Another female Marjorie Cameron joined
the group and started sleeping with her,
but their sexual encounters
had an occult end goal.
They wanted to impregnate
cameron with the spawn of Satan.
Apparently this required Hubbard.
Do you watch the couple while
they engaged in intercourse,
their behavior,
I've been surprisingly never
resulted in the spawn of Satan,
but these exploits did end in a lasting
relationship between Hubbard and
northrop.
The couple were married in 1946,
but Hubbard hadn't yet
divorced his first wife.
It took a year for his first wife to
find out that he had married again,
making Hubbard a big
interest for an entire year.
The divorce filings do not
paint a pretty picture.
Hubbards first marriage among the
accusations included in the papers is that
systematic torture beatings that
strangulations and scientific torture
experiments.
Well,
among the things hubbards first wife
was subjected to wants divorce stands,
once again,
monogamous harbored a northrop,
moved to Laguna Beach,
then to Georgia,
and they finally settled in New Jersey.
It was that,
but he began the crafting the work that
served as the basis for scientology
on May the fifth,
19,
50 that work,
but it was introduced to the world.
The publication of dianetics,
the modern science of mental health,
brought hubbards ideas about
psychology to the masses.
Within months.
The book was selling at a
rate of thousands a week
and it was translated into
several languages,
essentially dianetics stores and that,
uh,
memories which Hubbard referred to as
end grams are the reason that people
experienced psychological pain and
its associated health problems.
In the book,
he described how people can release
their in grams and work towards becoming
clear.
This is the term he used for being cured
of all the ills caused by an grants
even alleged that he cured his own war
injuries through the use of dianetics.
And he even said that leukemia was caused
by an angry and could be cured through
dianetics.
Leukemia is evidently
psychosomatic in origin,
and at least eight cases of leukemia had
been treated successfully by dianetics.
After medicine had traditional,
they'd given up the source of leukemia,
has been reported to be an
engram containing the phrase,
it turns my blood or water pub as well.
He was one who never understate
his achievements and he
had no doubts about what
dianetics could mean for the
world and for human health.
A milestone for comparable to his
discovery of fire and superior to his
invention of the wheel and the arch well
Hubbard was short about his theory of
psychology.
The scientific world
wasn't so quick to agree.
As the book continued to
sell and dianetics groups
began to pop up around the
nation.
Scientists and medical professionals
began to speak about their disbelief.
In dianetics,
the American Psychological Association
Dismiss dianetics as did scientific
American.
They said that hubbards ideas weren't
based in facts and he had nothing but
baseless promises.
Nonetheless,
the teachings of Dianetics,
they'd kept spreading.
Hubbard spends much of
1950 touring the country,
giving lectures on dianetics
and conducting seminars.
Dianetics groups sprouting up in large
cities and people started sending money
to the groups wanting to start on the
path to becoming clear or wanting to learn
how they could help others become clear
by being what is called a dianetics
auditor,
and it's all the traveling
and the middle of the theme,
how they couldn't keep his second marriage
going in architect keepers finances
in line,
he was having an affair with his public
relations assistance and dianetics
foundations around the
country were floundering only
a couple of years after his
book was an astounding success.
L Ron Hubbard was divorced a second time
and it wasn't looking like dianetics
was going to be any sort
of long term movement,
but hubbards well,
he had astounding charisma and he had a
theory that people that easily latched
onto and wanted to believe in.
One of the dianetics believers was
a millionaire named Don purcell.
He hadn't lost faith in
Hubbard's ends dianetics zs,
and he wanted to support the cause so
he poured money into a building and the
brand new foundation for
dianetics researching Kansas.
His support and his ideas,
they were no match for Hubbard
after he ends harbored,
had disagreements about the foundation
that organization fell apart and
ultimately ended up losing its money
to cover the depths of other lapsed
dianetics foundations.
Though the foundation in
Kansas didn't work out,
it wasn't a total loss for Hubbard.
He was able to launch Hubbard College
in the states and even met his next
brilliant that she was only 18
and to move together to Phoenix,
Arizona.
During this period,
Hubbard took the next leap forward in
sharing his ideas about psychology and the
human experience.
He started working on putting his ideas
about dianetics into a larger spiritual
and philosophical frame.
In other words,
it was creating scientology.
In 1954,
the Church of scientology
officially launched.
However,
Bas with much of scientology's history,
there is dispute about which
church was the official start.
Was it the one in California founded by
a member or was it hubbards organization
in New Jersey?
Either way,
Hubbard to put forth the ideas for the
structure of the church and it's his name
that will forever be
linked with scientology.
Alright,
so well,
what is scientology?
Well,
how about described it this way.
Scientology is the study of knowingness.
It increases one's knowingness,
but if a man were totally aware
of what was going on around him,
he would find it relatively simple to
handle any outbursts in that and according
to the churches website,
scientology teachings contained
answers for nearly everything,
a human good ones and know contains there
in our answers to life's most profound
mysteries,
the enigma of existence,
the riddle of death,
the realization of states not even
described in earlier literature.
Also from these works come scientology
technologies to rear children,
repair families,
educate,
organize and provide relief in
times of illness or suffering.
By 1956,
the Church of Scientology,
it was officially considered a church
in the eyes of the government and
therefore was a tax exempt organization.
Hubbard was making money
as people joins the church,
bought the materials and spends money to
move through the ranks of scientology.
One session with a scientology auditor
could cost a person that $300 and of
course you could not just have one
session as you kept working your way up.
Getting closer to being clear,
you have to spend more money to work
with auditors and to achieve more within
the church.
People were spending a lot of money to
be a member of scientology and to achieve
what Hubbard had promised
them was possible,
but just because scientology was growing
and was flushed with cash doesn't mean
it was without its problems.
Government is targeted,
the organization worried
about the consequences of
scientology on the health of
its members and there was also this
growing reputation for intimidation among
scientologists.
The Australian government even went so
far as to say that scientology was a
serious threat to the community medically,
morally and socially,
and it's adherence,
sadly diluted and often mentally ill.
The United States government
was also concerned.
In fact,
they had been watching Hubbard for years.
Some reports even say that the FBI had
interviewed him as early as 1951 and was
not happy with his mental state.
In 1963,
the Washington DC scientology
church was raided by the feds,
discovered just how much hubbard
was making off the church.
He was taking millions out of the coffers
of this organization and paying no
taxes to the government.
It was this the cause scientology
to lose its tax exempt status.
Public wasn't willing to let this
treatment by the US government stand,
though he created a new office within
scientology to deal with negative
publicity.
The scientologists in charge of
this office took aim aggressively.
Liberty accusing Scientology's,
detractors of libel and slander.
Others wanted to bring down his attack
is and was willing to do whatever it took
to do so.
Lower red blood sex crime,
actual evidence,
and it's what he wanted.
His publicity office defines on those
who were attacking scientology's
reputation.
Even with an aggressive
publicity approach.
A scientology didn't get their tax
exempt status back for another 30 years.
As a judge came under
attack from governments.
Hubbard saw a solution on the open
seas where governments couldn't get in.
It was this that caused him to
dream up another organization.
This one known as sea org.
The sea org was basically scientology
on the ocean with its members living
abroad.
Three ships that Hubbard had purchased.
There was a major cash though
to be welcomed into the sea org.
You have to sign a contract saying that
you would be loyal to scientology for 1
billion years.
Even though the group
was based aboard ships,
they still faced resistance
from governments.
The Greek government asked them to leave
Corfu after a year and there's Morocco
was no more welcoming to them being part
of the sea org and selling around the
world was not against to
being on a cruise ship.
There.
Instead,
there was little food,
long hours for those tending to the ship
and dirty clothes and linens were the
norm.
I would himself only lasted on
the open sea for a few years.
You have taken breaks on land
in the early 19 seventies,
but in 1975,
he returned to life on land for good.
Upon his return,
he settled in California and after
two decades in the spotlight,
l Ron Hubbard began to fade away from
his charismatic leadership role in the
church.
The is on the ocean and
not a raised scientology's.
Problems with the government's Hubbard
and his organization were being chased by
French and US authorities.
And didn't even manage to get themselves
embroiled in Morocco and political
issues.
While they're sea org ships would
dock that solution to these problems,
wants to keep themselves hidden.
The church kept fighting with Hubbard
pulling the strings and directing
operations that went to elaborate lengths
to infiltrate the federal governments
and disrupting investigations.
One operation called Snow White involved
everything from breaking into irs
offices to bugging the federal governments
to even infiltrating government staff
with scientology.
You could report back to the church.
A former scientologist said
that Hubbard always said,
never defends,
always attack.
This was gospel and that's pretty much
what the church did and it landed.
11 people in jail,
including hubbards wife.
As all of this was going on,
I was still hiding out at home.
He suffered from a number of
health problems throughout
the 19 seventies and 19
eighties,
a heart attack.
Pulmonary embolism,
injuries sustained in a motorcycle,
accidents and more.
He was obese and he smoked constantly.
The man simply wasn't healthy.
He moved around trying to stay out of
the public eye and away from potential
government action against him.
He had a team of teenagers
who took care of him,
washing his clothes and
holding out ashtrays for his
ever present cigarettes by
1996.
His health issues that mounted to a point
where they couldn't be overcome at the
age of 74,
l Ron Hubbard passed away after
suffering a stroke when he died.
He hadn't made a public
appearance in six years.
The New York Times said
mystery surrounding his
death just as a cloak to the
final years of his life.
He was cremated and his ashes were
scattered at sea by scientologists.
Seven years after Hubbard's death in 1993,
the irs reinstated the
church is tax exempt status.
The irs has not given an explanation
about why it was granted again,
but the scientologists good celebrate
then nearly $8,000,000,000 in assets.
We're once again safe from
taxation l Ron Hubbard's.
Life is fraught with contradictions
between church teachings and official
government documents,
and he's certainly a controversial figure.
A California judge ruling on a scientology
lawsuit didn't hide his feelings
about Hubbard at all.
The evidence portrays is a man who has
been virtually a pathological liar when
it comes to his history,
backgrounds and achievements.
He had egotism,
greed,
avarice,
lust for power and vindictiveness
and aggressiveness against a person's
perceived by him to be
disloyal or hostile.
Hubbard was a midwestern boy with an
imagination and that aptitude for language
that we didn't fare well at
George Washington University.
He was able to use this charisma and
considerable aptitude for propaganda to
build an organization that
remains largely intact today.
It's attracted the likes of Tom Cruise
and other Hollywood luminaries to Ed's
ranks,
and although it takes hits after,
hits in the press,
scientology marches on and l Ron
Hubbard has a legacy that lives on
controversial,
though it may be so.
I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday.
Also check out some of our other videos
which are over there on the right and as
always,
thank you for watching.